non pas du tout il ne fait rien avancer
du tout c'est une je désapprouve
absolument ce qu'il est en train de
faire qui est totalement contraire aux
intérêts de la france
d'abord envoyé jean marc ayrault porter
une lettre d'invitation monsieur poutine
pour ensuite dire qu'on ne sait pas si
on va le recevoir pour terminer les
russes dans une attitude plutôt
raisonnable pour éviter des incidents
qui ensuite nous entraîner dans une
escalade de mes aventures diplomatiques
ne sont pas bonnes pour le pays disent
que il reporte la visite
l'attitude de françois hollande est
absolument insupportable nous sommes
totalement alignée sur les états unis
d'amérique nous couvrons devant et c'est
une attitude qui n'est pas du tout
conforme aux intérêts de la france qui
n'a qu'un préalable je le répète faire
avancer la paix alex notamment mais
c'est pas cette manière là qu'on fait
avancer la paix en quoi est ce que le
fait de provoquer des incidents
diplomatiques de cette nature fait
avancer la paix veut provoquer une
discussion sérieuse exclusivement sur la
syrie ce bon tout ça n'est pas sérieux
surtout en menaçant monsieur poutine de
l'envoyer au tribunal pénal
international enfin qui est françois
hollande
à part la risée de l'univers à peine
était-il élus qu'il a accepté que les
nord-américains installe des bases de
missiles antimissiles soi disant pour
parer les missiles que l'iran était
censé vouloir nous tirer dessus
voici que entre temps il s'est
réconcilié avec l'iran mais que les
bases de missiles s'y trouvent et par
conséquent la russie est menacée vous
voyez bien que nous sommes en train
d'aller progressivement à une situation
de guerre alors ouvrons très réussi et
je pouvais dire que l'attitude de
françois hollande participe de l'
escalade qui conduit à la confrontation
avec la russie quant à lui françois
hollande ne cesse de dire des choses qui
n'ont pas de sens en temps poutine était
un ennemi puis un jour il reprend mon
vocabulaire et il dit la russie n'est
pas un ennemi mais un partenaire le
surlendemain il a encore changé
d'attitude et de vocabulaire
tout ça rend la france illisible
inefficace et absent en des conditions
de règlement du conflit en syrie on y
arrive